today we are going to create absolutely
incredible Virtual Worlds with these new
papers first Nvidia did something here H
but if the quality does not seem to be
too much better here then how does this
really help we'll find out together then
we are going to resculpt an image with
this collaboration between Intel and New
York University then we will become a
movie director and give directions to to
not people but get this images oh yes
and then we won't even need to direct
these images this AI technique directs
the video by itself dear fellow Scholars
this is two-minute papers with Dr car so
with nerves we are able to GA a bunch of
photos and have a technique Stitch it
together into a virtual world there are
models that can do this extremely
quickly for instance instant
neurographics this converges in a matter
of seconds which is kind of insane and
its quality is often even better than
its predecessors you can see a great
deal more detail in the hair and the
sweater and now let's see the new
technique ready to be blown away wait a
second this looks nearly the same so is
this better if it is better how well
what you see here is quality but quality
is just half of the story the other half
is size we haven't talked about that yet
the first technique is reasonably sized
but the quality is lacking then comes
instant neurographics quality much
better but the size is much larger and
now look at the new technique which
looks roughly the same but oh my it
packs the same quality
but in 1 the size fantastic in this
sense this is even better than the
legendary new technique gaussian
splatting which can create and now even
animate Virtual Worlds and this new one
is 50 times more compact than that crazy
now let's sculpt some images second
paper here the goal is to take an image
any image and then convert the people or
objects in it into a 3D model but not to
create a video game character from them
although that's quite nice too but no
not here here we now have knowledge
about the backside of this model too so
we can choose a new pose for our
character and apply some more magic to
put it back into the image with a new
pose we can even rotate them you name it
shifting these objects to new positions
is also possible and wait These are 3D
models so we can even apply deorations
to them carve out that bad boy and there
we go apart from some suspect artifacts
at the mouth region this one is almost
perfect or placing new ducklings or fish
into an image not a problem and this
concept gives us a great deal of control
over these images for instance how many
cherries would you like how about this
one and another one and another one the
consistency between the images is not
perfect but they are nearly the same and
just imagine what we will be capable of
just two more papers down the line my
goodness what a time to be alive and we
are not done with magic for today not
even close with this other work we can
apply some more artistic direction to
already existing images just look at the
arrows and this indicates our wishes as
to how the image should be moving and
Bam we get a video this works great for
camera movement you know what I wonder
what happens if I instruct this horse to
move that is so much more complex than
just camera movement so what happens
then now hold on to your papers fellow
scors and my goodness look at that the
AI understands how a horse should move
and synthesizes exactly that it is not
perfect not even close but this is once
again an excellent opportunity to invoke
the first law of papers what is that
well the first law of papers says that
research is a process do not look at
where we are look at where we will be
two more papers down the line remember
what Dolly one could do in terms of text
to image and then Dolly 2op dropped and
blew it out of the water and just
imagine what a dolly2 moment for this
kind of video synthesis could be wow and
now check this out here this AI
technique looked at videos of people in
real conversations and then all we need
is our audio input then get this it
creates virtual characters mouth
movements and even gestures
automatically so we can have
conversation in virtual world more
easily wait this adti is animated only
by my voice that's cool yeah let me show
you how it works I have to say the
synthesized movements are often
expressive I give you that but also
sometimes a little stiff mouth movement
is not that accurate yet but it is very
impressive that from just the audio all
this can be synthesized once again just
two more papers down the line and and
you might start seeing this out there in
the real world and I think this work is
a really good Showcase of how difficult
this problem is you see our brains are
wired to look at each other and read
each other's Expressions thus if even a
little hesitation just a tiny smirk if
just the slightest things are off we
immediately know that something is wrong
we are wired for that so making this
work properly will be incredibly
difficult but if something human
Ingenuity and the power of AI will be
able to do that if you're looking for
inexpensive Cloud gpus for AI Lambda now
offers the best prices in the world for
GPU Cloud compute no commitments or
negotiation required just sign up and
launch an instance and hold on to your
papers because with the Lambda GPU Cloud
you can now get On Demand h100 instances
and they are one of the first Cloud
providers to offer publicly available on
demand h100 accs did I mention they also
offer persistent storage so join
researchers at organizations like apple
MIT and ctech in using Lambda Cloud
instances workstations or servers make
sure to go to lamb.com
slapers to sign up for one of their
amazing in GPU instances today